you need to have your parents close to
you uh
because of some of the developments that
we've seen and some of the changes that
we've seen in the composition of the
labor pool especially with millions of
moms who were forced to drop out of uh
out of the workforce because of virtual
learning and all this so i guess i guess
that brings us to
back to the pandemic
and how that has
amplified accelerated decelerated trends
that you had seen uh in demographics and
in housing
yep
yeah the first thing um the thing that's
very obvious to anyone who's paying
attention is that you had a lot of
movement of households particularly
those looking for space whether that's
somebody who was in a multi-family unit
particularly urban poor
that wanted space so that means moving
to that suburban area and a lot of the
migration data that you can look at
whether it's post office or some of the
work that the pet has done um it shows
that the vast majority of urban
departures are to that same metro area
to the suburban areas up there so it
wasn't a situation of the new yorker
picking up and moving to austin as much
as it was the new yorker picking up and
moving to jersey or long island or
westchester and i'm going to interrupt
you one more time here zelman and
associates has done extraordinary work
about what you just mentioned and i
think there's a big misperception
out there that a lot of americans
uprooted and like moved halfway across
the country
yeah yeah and i think there's and
there's certainly some of that
especially among younger cohorts that
maybe um didn't have a core base of
where they were living but especially
when you think about families there's no
question that there was that push to the
suburbs and you saw this explosion in a
lot of these suburban markets around
urban areas
um so that was that that's very visible
i think it's debatable of how much of
that was local versus across state
borders that's where maybe the
conversation gets more fun
but when you think about housing as a
whole what i think the pandemic really
did on the march was it destroyed
incremental housing or household
formation
now most of the government data on this
topic is very volatile
there's a lot of surveys the government
produces that people use to try to
estimate household formation which is
essentially the change in households
it's the incremental number of
households coming to market
and household means if you weren't a
household before and you became one on
your own that's household formation
that's you moving out of your parents
and being independent you moving away
from college and being independent or
two roommates splitting up and both of
them having their own that's all
household formation
if you think about the pieces during the
pandemic
young adults move back home
at a at a pretty rapid clip and while
they've started to reverse that
the share of young adults living at home
today is still higher than in 2019 same
time and that's across all the young
cohorts so young adults have actually
been a headwind in that regard
there's two million fewer young adults
employed today around 48 million than
pre-pandemic it was close to 50 million
so you can kind of understand on the
margin why you'd have more young adults
living at home it's hard to underwrite
that and say well that was a
catalyst for household information so
the young piece i feel pretty confident
saying that's kind of net household
destruction that we have from the
pandemic
you think about deaths you obviously had
more people die than normal and if you
if you roll that through you had about
600 000 excess deaths
in 2020 you're probably going to be
closer to 450 500 this year
that's incrementally a three to four
hundred thousand household unit drag so
more people on average as you run that
through house at ship rates understand
how those people are living and then
immigration immigration is typically a
huge impact on incremental population
growth and household demand and you know
that immigration was down massively in
2020 and is still down significantly
this year
so you take each of those pieces and you
say well
there's it's very hard to argue that you
actually created housing demand during
payment it's very easy to say you
destroyed it on the margin
not to say you didn't have household
formation but you had a lot less than
what the trend line was
the perception is that well clearly the
pandemic was great for for housing and
household formation it's great for home
sales and it was great for
second homes but when we're trying to
get a core demographically driven
primary command it was actually
[Music]